White House
shamed into deleting Social Security
boast after Twitter fact checked uh the
Biden Administration was forced to
delete a Twitter post taking credit for
Boost and retired Social Security checks
Wednesday after social media
to users pointed out the increase was
tied to decades High inflation seniors
are getting the biggest decrease in
Social Security can you post this up so
we can see this how embarrassing is it
when the White House has to delete
something uh in Social Security checks
in 10 years though President Biden
leadership let me read this again
seniors are getting the biggest increase
in their Social Security checks in 10
years through President Biden's
leadership read the tweet from the
official White House account Tuesday
afternoon Twitter opened the note to
that claim that said readers added
context they thought people might want
to know seniors will receive a large
social security benefit increase due to
annual cost of living adjustment which
is based on the inflation rate note said
linking to Social Security
Administration website for an
explanation on the Nixon era legislation
behind this increase please okay for all
of those that thinks that I'm just a
biting apologist like listen clearly
nice try there sleepy Joe nice freaking
try here buddy I saw this I was like
no just like seniors are getting the
biggest increase in their social
security in 10 years thanks to Joe Biden
President Joe Biden's leadership and
this is nobody nobody it's because
inflation is [ __ ] north of eight
percent yeah and this is by law what
needs to happen so seniors who are
living on fixed income right can live
because Joe Biden doesn't want old
people dying in their homes in the
headlines so of course you need to do
this protect people people need money to
pay the bills but of course they need
money to pay the gas every the grocery
everything we get it nice try Joe nice
try Karine St Pierre John Pierre but it
wasn't sure
but doesn't it feel good that it's
finally happening to the other side
because if you think about it every
Trump trump was getting checked fact
check every two seconds now that they're
getting checked can you imagine all the
[ __ ] that they've done in the past two
years that nothing's happened but
there's a difference between fact check
and the leading
especially from the white house because
here's what you think about one who the
hell tweeted that who approved it who
checked it what is the pro you're the
White House if you need this much
verification to have a tweet go out how
the hell are you gonna run the world how
the hell are you going to run the
country if you can't handle one simple
account of Twitter can't you have five
people that check something before they
say all it takes is one person to say
well president before we tweet this out
this is not because of you yeah this is
because of the structured setup no no no
just put it out there we're gonna need
it for the midterms it's going to show
us we're doing a good thing but bad
thing about how like now this is two
years later like uh he finally got has
Twitter how much [ __ ] have they tweeted
that was a lie in these past two years
disappointed again forget it there's
nothing you can do about it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you